today is read across america day it's an
effort to try and encourage
more children to read and to learn and
to start doing that at a young age
you know while the pandemic canceled
many of the in-person reading events a
lot of virtual events are taking place
right here in las vegas
all with the goal to get kids teenagers
even adults
excited about reading to know that a
child really is enjoying a book or to
say that i really like those words that
i'm hearing
that means so much to me and it makes me
it fills me with a lot of joy just
because i know that it's going to help
them later on in life
so here are some tips for early readers
or if you have an early reader in your
household
be an example for the kids have them
make predictions about stories using
pictures and
explain what's happening going forward
finally make sure that students are
children they pick out words they
recognize in books and then they can
repeat them
it can help with their confidence read
across america coincides with the
birthday of dr
seuss but this year dr seuss publisher
says it's also going to stop
selling some of his books six titles
will no longer be published because
according to the company they quote
portray people in ways that are hurtful
and wrong you can see the titles of
those books on your screen
the company says it worked with a panel
of experts to reach that decision